avoir mode sur la chaîne pour nous c'est
un énorme honneur c'est un voilà on est
on est très très très heureux sache le
mode on va regarder un extrait tout de
suite on va en parler juste après et
c'est vrai qu'on est là on est comme des
fous voilà je te le dis les gentils ah
non mais vraiment moche mais voilà c'est
la classe
[Musique]
bonjour à tous sauvés l'océan c'est
sauver l'homme
tous les écosystèmes marins dans leur
incroyable variété recèle d espèce
fascinante et des modes de
fonctionnement très inspirant pour les
chercheurs observez le grand bleu et en
retirer des mécanismes applicable à nos
sociétés et à nos quotidiens voilà notre
défi or depuis trop longtemps l'humanité
à considérer les mers et les océans
comme une gigantesque poubelle un
lassabe le mans nous n'avons eu de cesse
d'abandonner dans les profondeurs tout
ce dont nous n'avions plus besoin 10
millions de tonnes de déchets sont ainsi
rejeter dans la mer chaque année à
travers le monde et aujourd'hui toute
cette pollution revient comme un
boomerang dans nos assiettes
alors on devrait avoir la solution
surtout que la suite là c'est que ça
revient dans nos assiettes parce qu'on
fait on mangerait l'équivalent d'une
carte bleue de plastique par personne et
par semaine enfin les stic est en fait
les particules de plastique tout ce que
tu vas jetée à la mer depuis des
décennies entre les deux guerres on
s'est partagé des armements les amis et
dans le fond des océans tout ça a
complètement intégré le cycle de l'eau
le cycle de l'air et que les nano
particules de plastique elles reviennent
dans une assiette de pression et ça
revient bien parce que les
téléspectateurs qui m'intéresse c'est du
concret conséquent mode nous dit chaque
semaine on une carte de crédit castadi
la manche lui que normalement
je lui mais voilà quand même aimé tirer
l'équivalent d'une carte de crédit on se
dit là on va tous y pensent et chaud que
tous les gens qui nous regardent en
direct où il pensait maintenant c'est
que souvent quand on parle des océans et
on fait souvent la remarque on dit oui
mais moi j'habite pas près de la mer
qu'est ce que c'est pourquoi ça aurait
un impact sur ma vie et c'est pour ça
que je sais que d'expliquer que les
océans c'est à la fois l'oxygène que
l'on respire puisqu'un poumons sur deux
ne respire que grâce à l'océan c'est
près de 22000 médicaments qui sont
étudiées qui vont c'est vraiment la
trousse à pharmacie de demain c'est les
énergies de demain c'est aussi la mer
c'est la régulation du climat c'est
l'alimentation c'est vraiment la marmite
de l'humanité il ya un humain sur trois
qui mangeraient pas de protéines si elle
est pâle et les océans justement pour
assurer cette survie alimentaire ça va
être long c'est avec eux il ya
énormément d'eau sur la planète mais en
fait l'eau disponible c'est seulement 3%
l'eau douce et sur 7 3% c'est seulement
0 3% qui est possible pour l'homme est
en fait à 300 millions de personnes dans
le monde qui boivent l'eau de la mer
avec des dessalinisateur comme israël
l'espagne l'australie donc en fait les
océans scellé à la fois les trois quarts
du globe c'est là où la vie est née
parce que la vienne et dans la
profondeur des hausses ayant il ya 3,8
milliards d'années donc on est tous nés
dans la profondeur des océans et wash
actes et passionné des abysses il ya
tant de choses bien
et je m'habille ce jeu m'a bien se
perdre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tous les fonds de la même et en fait
aujourd'hui ce qui était fascinant c'est
qu'on retourne à la mer et je prends
toujours cette image du dauphin c'est
que dauphin était un animal marin qu'on
aime bien il a été un moment donné
pendant son évolution en animal
terrestre on retrouve dans ses nageoires
des phalanges il a rejoint ensuite la
mer pour y assurer sa survie est
vraiment c'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
et dans ces petits programmes courts ils
ont passé un peu tous les jours soit
tous les jours à partir de lundi sur des
12 heures 40 à ça c'est un kiff ça tu
vois où c'est vrai en train d'aider
voilà moi je vais regarder que je te
regarde et où l'effet ben ça va j'espère
que ça va pouvoir éveiller les
consciences parce qu'à chaque fois c'est
les solutions dans celui là on va parler
des bioplastiques colo fabrique à partir
par exemple de la carapace de crevettes
et avec de la soie et on va faire le
plastique de demain ça va être des
médicaments la peau de requin qui permet
de recouvrer interpellent au chili que
non exactement
la peau de requin qui va permettre aux
bactéries de ne pas s'accrocher parce
que la peau de requin empêche
l'adhérence des bactéries et donc elle
va recourir interne aux hôpitaux pour
empêcher la prolifération des maladies
mais ça va être aussi le petit
coquillage le co2 magicien qui a une
haine anti douleur mille fois plus
puissant que la morphine et qui est
aujourd'hui commercialisé enfin c'est
tout ce qui vient de la mer que l'on
connaît pas tamare les navigateurs il
disait les français la mer ils savent
pas ce que c'est c'est ce qu'ils ont
dans le dos quand il regarde la
signature il a raison j'arrive vraiment
j'ai eu la draf au téléphone tu dis amen
mois avec moi dans des abysses
qui obtient on part tous les deux autres
programmes sur s'est vite je pense
vraiment qu'il faut qu'on fasse un
programme mais j'en ai jamais parlé de
maicon dont ces ricains mode sur la
chaîne donc c'est un bonheur tu
j'adorerais tue pas qu'on parte ensemble
six ans est donné on va dans les abysses
non mais c'est sûr j'adorerais non non
non mais sans rigoler on fore programme
pour ces vite et comme ça tu m'expliques
parce que moi je comprends rien je
connais rien donc comme ça au moins tu
m'expliques tous les trucs en voilà cinq
ans situation dit la salle de juin une
style je n'aurais pas ce que c'est c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui que ma fondation
qui sont relancés classe de mer en
france et notamment à destination des
zones d'éducation prioritaire à
destination des aides pourquoi parce que
il faut aller voir parce que souvent
quand j'en parle enfin là on a réussi à
faire quelque chose de vraiment très
complet avec franck appietto mais en au
final j'ai donc et aux nombres asus
cambre apprend que j'adore les habits
mais c'est vrai que d'aller voir et donc
c'est vrai que le fait de relancer les
classes de mer en france pour emmener
nos jeunes découvrir le milieu marin
certains vraiment habite pas si loin de
la mer et ils ont jamais vu ils sont
jamais partis en vacances et c'est vrai
que de comprendre du coup que la france
elle est la deuxième puissance maritime
mondiale et c'est pour ça qu'il va y
avoir la semaine prochaine à un grand
congrès international voulue par le
président la république monsieur
emmanuel macron qui va avoir lieu à
brest et ça sera réunir tous les chefs
d'état sur les enjeux des océans
j'allais y aller ou pas a naturellement
moi je travaille sur la thématique de
l'éducation avec l'unesco est une des
ambassadrices du sommet et je vais
rapporter auprès des chefs d'état une de
mes résolutions qui est l'urgence à
éduquer parce que il faut vraiment qu'on
fasse des grands programmes éducatifs
dans tout milieu scolaire comme on le
fait en france avec jean michel blanquer
c'est à des programmes dans les
maternelles primaires collèges lycées
pour qu'on comprenne le lien entre
l'homme et l'océan et qu'on comprenne
que la france est la deuxième puissance
maritime ne croyons pas non non un vrai
rôle à jouer on a on a vraiment un
leadership à prendre sur ces enjeux là
c'est à dire qu'il faudrait vraiment
aujourd'hui qu'on s'assure que les
océans sont pas piller pour donner un
peu une idée la france par une idée de
la pêche la france on est le troisième
pêcheurs européens quand l'europe elle
capture 4%
l'asie la chine s'est pratiquement 50
n'ont pas dire qu entre tes pêcheurs
français qui sont sur des petits bas
bien sûr one 12 m et entre eux les
gigantesques truc qui parcourt les
océans qui raclent tous qui prennent les
tons qui les congèle direct qui les
coupe en tronçons il ya aujourd'hui 60%
de la haute mer qu'est cents
juridictions n'ya pas de réglementation
y apparaître gouvernance moyen peut y
puiser ce qu'on veut donc comment tu
veux quoi qu on avance plus on avait vu
ce pêcheur qui avait cavegoal et ceux
qui sont payants n'avait pas sélectionné
c'est un pêcheur français qui disait que
voilà qui qui s'en sortaient plus
passeur que quand on régule bien les
choses et quand on met en avant nous en
france la pêche artisanale ce qui est le
cas avec des bons produits de savoir où
est-ce qu'ils ont été pêchés avec des
labels comme le label msc qu'on va
retrouver même dans les plus grands faso
disons maintenant du poids sont
labellisés
de l'autre côté on essaie de lutter
contre la pêche illicite parce que savez
qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de poissons
le péché il ya plus dans un cauet rans a
déjà des pressions qui sont pêchés
illégalement qui vont être déchargés sur
des porcs de complaisance tu veux à 7 à
10 millions de tonnes de poissons qui
sont pêchés mais qui sont rejetés à la
mer parce qu'il nous plaisent pas parce
qu'ils sont trop petits trop gros
correspond donc pas aux quotas dans
gaspillage et puis tu à l'avenir qui l
aquaculture sauf que tu as un petit
souci aujourd'hui c'est qu'en fait tu
vas prendre genre 3 à 4 kg de poissons
tu vas en faire de la farine et tu va
nourrir un petit lot et quand c'est du
thon rouge tu dois prendre 9 à 10 kg de
poissons qc en farine pour nourrir ton
kg de thon rouge c'est donc tu vois tu
as un truc qui qui qui va pas cru ce que
nous dit on apprend plein de choses
le dauphin que tu adores le dauphin et
pêche avec un cercle de bulle autour des
espèces et il fait un système de
d'échographie il détecte si les
tonnelles son plein quand les femelles
sont en gestation il les met de côté
nous on mangerait pas une vache à lait
encore son veau dans le ventre et donc
sir elton sourire j'ai dormi en du
dauphin il a fait des études de médecine
aux canaries on a mis les femelles
poisson à l'écart et aujourd'hui on voit
que les populations reviennent donc je
veux dire qu'il faut il ya aussi
l'espoir enfin ce que j'essaye de dire
dans ces programmes courts c'est que ya
des choses qui vont pas mais il est
temps de prendre conscience du problème
et de d'étudier ces océans qui sont une
bibliothèque de solutions dont on
connaît que quelques rayonnages